we can't get enough of and eMac the show
packs a serious emotional punch we've
rounded up ten of the biggest scenes
that will put you in your fields you're
scaring me you should be scared now
let's jump right into the ten most
emotional scenes on Andy Mac it's
official few things are more emotional
than romantic relationships dating
crushing and breaking up are all an
emotional roller coaster from beginning
to end one of the most addictive parts
of Andy Mack is her ongoing crush on the
dreamy Jonah back everyone who watches
Angie Mack knows just how much she's
into him fans everywhere were dying for
the ship to be official there were so
many moments that almost sealed the deal
the tension was getting pretty serious
we all held our breath in season two and
it seems like the relationship was
doomed for good when Andy and Jonah
finally had a conversation to clarify
what they were to each other it didn't
go as well as we were hoping Andy walked
away knowing that Jonah wasn't her
boyfriend the hearts of fans everywhere
saying
luckily the story didn't end there the
universe seemed to step in to help bring
the pair together things got more
emotional and romantic than ever
Jonah even wrote Andy a song to win her
over can you imagine your crush singing
to you in front of a ton of people that
part alone was pretty darn emotional
hearing that song gave Andy the courage
to tell Jonah what she wanted Andy has
something she'd like to tell Jonah did
you really have to you clearly weren't
going to everyone breathed a sigh of
satisfaction when this relationship was
finally declared official Buffy's mom
returns being part of a military family
is really tough
there are tough situations at every turn
you have to move frequently there are
rules about where you can live and
sometimes family members have to leave
for long periods of time
there are huge fears when your loved
ones are away from home for Buffy she
knows the struggle to well for one and a
half seasons we didn't get to meet
Buffy's mom she was on active duty and
deployed overseas for a really long time
her family missed her desperately and
couldn't wait for the day that they
would be united writers on the show took
an opportunity to give Buffy and the
fans a beautiful emotional moment
everyone loves viral videos of soldiers
coming home it's
burst of joy that is nearly universal
after all we all have someone we love
and want to be near when the show
introduced Buffy's mom they decided to
tap into that beloved trend the scene
plays out just like a moving viral video
Buffy is on the basketball court and
focused on her game until she looks up
and catches sight of her mom entering
the gym she runs to her and wraps her up
in the most emotional hug ever the Joey
at that moment is palpable no one can
resist the happiness of such a pure
reunion mom the first time a child calls
their parents mom or dad is a very
emotional time in most conventional
families this happens very early on in
some cases it's even a baby's first
words and Emax family is anything but
conventional Andy's first word actually
was mama the fact that she said it to
her grandmother and not her mom was a
tipping point it's at wheels in motion
that would affect her life and her
family for over a decade after all that
the very first time Andy called Beck's
mom was a heart-stopping moment this
moment is the exact opposite of Andy's
first word instead of being filled with
resentment and disappointment Beck's is
overjoyed the scene really begins when
Andy shows up in the middle of the night
Cece is dropping her off with a suitcase
she's not exactly nice to Beck's but she
seems to give her blessing in a really
passive-aggressive way Andy is moving in
with her real mother
the moment is already really emotional
but Andy takes it a step further
she calls Beck's his house home and then
adds you're my mom
Beck's breaks out into a huge smile
she's full of joy to finally get the
moment her heart has ached for for so
long
meant to be we can't help but eat up a
story about star-crossed lovers Beck's
and Bowie really seemed to have some
serious vibes it's like the whole
universe is rooting for them Bowie
spends 13 years not knowing Andy was his
daughter when he found out he came
running back having him around brings up
new feelings in Beck's
every five minutes imagine telling your
little sister that you're really her mom
and adjusting to that while your ex is
lurking around
Bowie feels like signs are pointing him
back to Beck's
something intervened let me guess the
universe he finds a bunch of photos of
her at concert venues and feels like
they were meant to be after both he and
Becks confess they still have feelings
for each other
he just happens to find an engagement
ring in his pocket it's like the romance
police for trying to frame them he even
plays her a song he wrote for her
surrounded by romantic candles does it
get any sweeter or corny er than that
these moments have forever sealed the
deal in the hearts and minds of fans
Becks and Bowie are simply meant to be
together
that candlelight serenade was such an
epic moment
Bowie's video bonding with the parents
you've met later in life can be awkward
that's not a relationship that develops
overnight when Bowie Andy's dad came
back into the picture it was awkward
Bowie is eager to get to know his kid
and Bowie struggles to find his place in
Andy's life when he shows up he rubs
Andy the wrong way she finds his antics
annoying he follows her around for two
days as the pair try to get to know each
other and bond Bowie plans to surprise
Andy with a heartfelt video about her
his plan catastrophic leave backfires
Andy walks in on Bowie editing the video
he's using her computer and looking
through her photos when she walks in
Andy is understandably pretty upset with
her new dad she barely knows the guy and
now he's snooping through her files
that's not cool Andy loses it and tells
Bowie off he takes the hint and leaves
that's when Beck's discovered the sweet
video she watches it with Andy and
they're both tearing up butwe narrates
that he's just become a dad and even
though he's only known Andy for two days
he can't remember what life is like
without her this was the first major
breakthrough in their relationship it
was huge and heartfelt
Buffy says goodbye it's never easy to
leave your home especially when it isn't
your own choice tons of kids know the
struggle all too well
parents can decide to move for a lot of
different reasons in Buffy's case her
mom is in the military military families
tend to move pretty frequently saying
goodbye to your school friends and
neighborhood is one of the hardest
things anyone can do anyone who has
moved as a kid can tell you it's a
non-stop tidal wave of emotion in one
particularly difficult moment Buffy lets
her mom in on some of those emotions Pat
is reassigned to a station in Phoenix
Arizona
Buffy is heartbroken and her friends are
in a panic they don't want her to leave
Andy hatches a plan for Buffy to stay at
her house until the end of the school
year Pat sees how much Buffy Andy
siress mean to her it's hard not to get
swept away at the moment hat tells her
daughter that they've been apart so long
and just been reunited she doesn't want
to let her go again Buffy doesn't want
to leave her mother either in a moment
that surprised a lot of fans
Buffy chose to go with her mother it was
so sweet panic attack anxiety can strike
anyone at any time
one of the most frightening symptoms of
anxiety is an anxiety attack
these attacks are terrifying they can
cause dizziness shortness of breath and
more anxiety is a pretty serious topic
for a kids show to cover and some found
the show's portrayal kind of problematic
at Cyrus's Bar Mitzvah Andi is keeping
her distance from Jonah she thinks
they've recently broken up and she's way
not over it
Dona never meant to dump her Andi makes
a handsome new friend at the party he
flirts with Andi in front of Jonah and
he begins to realize she may be lost
forever
the idea that he was really broken up
with Andi sends him physically reeling
this teen portrays the attack as making
Jonah dizzy and disoriented at one point
he even calls out for help
this scene perfectly captures the awful
feeling of helplessness that can come
with a panic attack
luckily Cyrus's dad was nearby mr.
Goodman is a psychiatrist he immediately
identifies what's happening to Jonah
Jonah says he thought he was going to
die his team is powerful and brings
awareness to just how serious these
attacks are lots of fans could relate to
anxiety so it was a deep dive coming out
the Disney Channel broke brave new
grounds for children's programming in
this moving scene never before had any
show faced this tough issue with such
blunt feeling for some people LGBT
rights are controversial there are a lot
of societal and cultural pressures for
people who don't fit inside the box
because of that coming out can be really
scary it's also deeply profound for many
people coming out is the single most
important moment in their lives
supporting a person when they take this
huge step is so important
Andy Mack is at its core a show about
relationships from its first episode it
pushed the boundaries of what kids TV
could be this tense moment is no
exception
throughout the show Cyrus Andy Buffy and
Jonah are best friends they navigate a
lot of difficult moments and support
each other as Syrus develops feelings
for Jonah he
Eliza's he needs someone to talk to he
chooses Buffy in this incredibly written
scene he breaks down in tears
Joshua rush who plays Cyrus on the show
said the scene held emotional enormity
we can't agree more
Buffy steps up and give Cyrus the love
and support he needs the scene is so
real and riveting Beck's confesses and
Emax spent 12 years and 11 months and 29
days of her life living a lie on the eve
of her 13th birthday she learned an
earth-shattering secret that would
change her life forever imagine growing
up with two loving parents that you
looked up to now imagine finding out
that those people are your grandparents
it must have been so shocking for Andi
to have her world turned upside down in
one moment she found out that who she
thought was her sister was actually her
mom not only did Andy have to reevaluate
her place in her family but she had to
face two heartbreaking betrayals the
first was her abandonment when max left
home and left Andy behind she made a
choice she could never take back we
can't imagine what Andy went through
when she realized that Becks chose to
leave her behind the second betrayal was
the 12 years of Lies her grandparents
told your family is supposed to be
people you can trust no matter what this
kind of secret could leave scars for
life
Andy faced all of that pain and
confusion with grace she found the
strength to forgive and let go Andy is
obviously incredibly strong let us know
in the comments your favorite moments
from the show we hope you love to this
roundup of the most emotional and emak
moments don't forget to subscribe to the
things for more videos like this one
[Music]